Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie. This is gonna be my Captain America #1 video.
Just be careful for spoilers from that comic book.
Everybody's freaking out. It's turned into a bit of a funny thing now
because of all of the memes people are creating.
So what's happened is is Captain America has had a refresh
in his main comics. Steve Rogers has not been Captain America in the comics for a while.
He's been old Steve Rogers. He's got the serum taken out of him.
He took a lot of the story arcs that you would normally give to Nick Fury.
But, because of DC Rebirth, a lot of people think that Marvel wanted to refresh Captain America.
So they de-aged him. So we got young Captain America again.
But, because Sam Wilson is now Captain America, with the vibranium shield,
and they didn't wanna take that away from him, they wanted a compelling twist so Mission Accomplished.
Now everybody thinks- and this is getting to the spoiler part- he is a Hydra Agent.
He's been Hydra this whole time. But, if you've read comics, you'd know they have some of the most
ridiculous set-up twists that they pay off later and there's a big reversal.
So no, I definitely don't think that they're saying that Cap has been evil this whole time.
I think there'll be some twist and he'll be a triple agent or something like that. But when you read the actual
comic, you kinda get an idea for where they might be taking it. Now, I haven't read the whole
series. It hasn't been released yet. But there's all these flashbacks. It shows that Steve Rogers' mother was a
victim of abuse. She was being recruited by a Hydra agent that beat up her abusive husband.
So considering this year is the 75th anniversary of Captain America, and they're not gonna turn him
into a nazi on his 75th birthday, I think the story's gonna be a larger exploration of the true meaning of freedom.
Like you could see in the flashbacks that Cap was the perfect target for Hydra. Victim of abuse, someone who
felt powerless. Hydra comes along and says "Hey, we can make you feel very powerful."
So there's a number of ways that that could play out that lead to this big reveal in the end of the comic where
he's like "Hail Hydra". I'm gonna talk a little bit about his arc during "Captain America: Civil War" the movie
so careful for spoilers from that. He has that big conversation with Tony Stark. "That ain't freedom"
He doesn't wanna sign the Sokovia Accords - work for the government - because he seen what happened when
government agendas change-I mean he's really thinking of the Nazis in that situation.
He has his own idea of the true meaning of freedom and he doesn't wanna serve someone else's idea of freedom,
worrying that that might end up changing later. If someone decides that their idea of freedom
isn't true freedom. So I think whatever ends up playing out over this Captain America arc, that idea of
freedom will remain true to the character. It's just that the new backstory bits will have him hopping
around a bunch of different places that you never expected. They want you to buy the comics
so of course the first issue has to like poke everyone like "Oh my god, what the hell just happened?"
And a lot of people have said that you know, mostly the people that are getting upset about this
are non-comic-book readers. That's not necessarily true. It reminds me of a big twist on "The Flash"
season 2 TV show so careful for spoilers from "The Flash" with respect to the Jay Garrick character.
There was a big twist in the middle of the season and Mark Waid- long time Flash writer
and probably the most knowledgeable comic-book creator in the world, like he has this almost autistic
memory for certain comic-book panels, like he could  pick out specific comic-book panels
if you give him the issue number. That's how much he knows comic-books. So he got really upset with
this big twist that posited that Jay Garrick might have been Hunter Zolomon- Zoom- the whole time
so he was upset at the idea that Jay Garrick of the TV show had never been a hero.
But then the producers of "The Flash" TV show were like "Wait! Wait! Wait! We would never do that
to Jay Garrick. We would never trample over his memory. Just wait."
And so he backed up a little bit and was like "Oh my God. I'm sorry, I didn't realize that I was jumping the gun
on this." So they wound up with this great payoff for Jay Garrick at the end of the season and Mark Waid
was like "Thank you so much! I am so happy with the way this played out." A lot of you are probably
familiar with the Wally West run that he wrote in the comics. There was a storyline called
"The Return of Barry Allen". In it, Barry came back and was acting like a jerk so Mark Waid
tweeted this out the other day where he was like "If I'd tried to pull this off today, like the Captain America twist,
people would kill me. Not even joking." But, in the comics, what ended up happening during that "Return
of Barry Allen" arc was that it was revealed that the asshole version of Barry Allen was secretly
Eobard Thawne masquerading as Barry Allen. So Wally West gives him the beatdown. "You're no
Barry Allen. You're just an asshole." So if you feel bad at getting really upset about this Hydra twist,
do not get upset. A lot of people have this reaction. Even people who have been reading comic-books their
whole life. And understand that this is just the way the publishing game is played. There has to be
a really interesting hook before they pay it off and before some big reversal where it's like
"Oh Cap was pretending to be a double agent for Hydra when really he was a triple agent trying to make
Hydra think that he was a double agent but then there was a big reversal". So there's just so
many winding twists that are gonna happen in this story. I think they just wanted to make it really interesting
given what's happening with DC Rebirth right now because that's an amazing story. And anytime
DC does something really amazing, Marvel has to try to do something amazing too.
It's just the way the game is played. But here's my big question for you guys. Or it's not really a question.
In the comments below, write in your funniest joke for this text bubble here. There have been some really good ones.
But in related news, if you guys haven't seen it yet, be sure to see "X-Men: Apocalypse". I'm gonna be doing an easter egg video soon.
There's new "Game of Thrones" coming. There's all kinds of 90s X-Men stuff that we need to talk about.
So be sure to subscribe to get that and "Hail Hydra"
I'm waiting to hear stories from my friends that they like spit their drink out at the person they were sitting next to
when they read this. "Oh my God! I can't believe he's Hydra!"
But while you guys wait for my next video to post, you can click here for my non-spoilery "X-Men: Apocalypse" review.
And you can click here for my "DC: Rebirth" explainer. Thank you so much for watching everybody. Let's high-five. I'll see you guys tonight.